What's the difference between a human
and a puddle? Membranes. A membrane is
like a protected envelope, and it does
two important things. One, it separates
the inside of the cell from the outside
environment, and two, it helps control
what comes in and out of the cell.
Membranes are made out of phospholipids,
molecules with hydrophilic and
hydrophobic parts. When many of these
phospholipids get together, they make a
membrane. Sitting in the membrane are
several types of really cool proteins
that control how the cell works. We
have receptors, ion channels, and
structural proteins. Receptors sit in
the cell membrane, with their tails
inside and their arms outside. They
connect the passing proteins and tell
the inside of the cell what is going on
outside. They're kind of like our
senses, and there are many kinds. Ion
channels are little tunnels, letting
things like potassium, calcium and
sodium through the membrane that the
cell needs to survive. There are also
structural proteins that help the cell
keep its shape, move around and connect
to other cells. All these proteins live
within or on the cell membrane and are
free to move between the phospholipids
in order to get to where they need to
be. Why would they need to move? Well,
some proteins on the membrane send out
signals to get what they need.
Sometimes the signal of a lonely
protein is too small, so they find
strength in numbers and move together
on the membrane to have a louder call.
All living things have cells. Some
living things are made from one cell,
like bacteria, and some are made from
many cells, like animals. Although both
of these types of cells have membranes,
a big part of what makes them different
is on the inside. Just like we have
organs in our bodies, animal and plant
cells have organelles, small organs, in
theirs. And just like each of our
organs has its own role in keeping us
alive, each organelle has its own role
in keeping the cell alive. Each of
these tiny organelles also have
membranes that control what they let in
and out. For example, mitochondria grab
ions and move them through the membrane
to make energy to fuel the cell.
Another example is the nucleus where
the DNA is stored. Its membrane
protects the DNA from things that could
damage it. Membranes are important for
life and keep us from being puddles.